Now, we can see that quarter three revenue fell well below predictions.
We have all seen the numbers?
The data shows that customer retention was a sticky area.
I mean, if you follow this line…
Boo! Boo! Come on, Gibbons! Nobody can see that!
You should have sent it out in advance.
I can make copies.
You don't know how to use the machines! You don't! You don't!
And the rest of you, where is the energy?
Where is the focus?
Come on, let's pick up the pace, hey! C'mon! Woo!
Does he work here?
He's a big fan of the company.
Jonesy! Take us to the next item on the agenda!
Just chip it, man! You're the greatest!
Right. Well, yes, we don't have a formal agenda per se.
You stink, Jonesy!
A foul! That's a foul!
This is not how you lead a team!
What kind of meeting is this?
Nobody understands what it's for!
No, that's not true! Of course they do.
Tell him what our objective is.
Well, I don't even really understand what it is we do here.
You do meetings,...
...long, tedious meetings that amount to nothing.
I'm seeing no structure, sloppy preparation.
Nobody is prepared to attack the goal!
I've spent too long rooting for this company to watch it fall apart.
We've had a bad first half,...
...but we are still in it!
I want to see hustle and efficiency!
I want to see teamwork!
I want this to be the greatest comeback in the history of meetings!